this is from AP the AP Oxford University
press has named Riz as its word of the
Year highlighting the popularity of a
term used by Generation Z to describe
someone's ability to attract or seduce
another person it topped Swifty which is
an enthusiastic fan of Taylor Swift
situationship an informal romantic or
sexual relationship and prompt an
instruction given to an artificial
intelligence program well that's not
even a new word uh it to those in the
annual decision by experts at the
publisher of the multivolume Oxford
English Dictionary the four finalists
were selected by a public vote and the
winner was announced on Monday the Riz
is believed to come from the middle of
the word Charisma and can be used as a
verb as in to Riz up or chat someone up
publisher said it speaks to how younger
Generations create spaces where they own
and Define the language they use from
activism to dating and wider culture as
genz comes to have more impact on
society differences and perspectives and
lifestyle play out in language 2 now I'm
only reading this because it highlights
kind of this weird aspect of modern
society which is that um our
vocabularies are
shrinking like the average vocabulary
now is is like 10 words okay it's it's
almost it's it's just 10 words and
Grunts and pictures um it's so the
vocabulary is shrinking and yet we're
inventing new words every year so
there's never been more words invented
and also there's never been fewer words
known or used and it's a very strange
dichotomy and I think it's because all
of our new words are just variations of
old words so they're taking old words
and they're shortening them or they're
combining them so it's like we're doing
the English language what we've done to
churches you know they go into Old
churches that used to be ornate and
beautiful and they intentionally make
them crude and ugly um or with modern
art people used to sculpt gorgeous
impressive figures out of stone or wood
and now they just plop a wood block down
and they call that
art in fact I saw someone post a
minimalist they said it was a minimalist
AR uh a minimalist artistic nativity set
and that was on sale somewhere and it's
just blocks of wood instead of Jesus
Mary and Joseph and the Shepherds and
wise men everything it's just it's just
the blocks of wood so like the wood that
they in the past they would have like
carved into figures now it's just the
wood it's just the
block and uh that's what we're doing
with language we're replacing distinct
and beautiful words with blocks of
wood
Riz what the hell is that Riz I mean
ironically if you use the word Riz then
you have none that's the irony of
it that's a word you use if you have the
IQ and personality of uh a
barnacle like what's wrong with just
saying Charisma why can't you just say
that Charisma is a good word Charisma is
a meaningful word there's nothing wrong
with that word just say Charisma now
sure it has three syllables it takes
slightly longer to
say but you can do it I believe in you
you can you can manage to say Charisma
it's not hard you can say the whole
thing it's three syllables you can
actually say it it takes like one
millisecond
longer it's not like you're so busy that
you have to shorten all the shorten all
the words now or use pictures in place
of like actual
sentences and and if you didn't know any
better you look around you think well
people are so busy they don't have any
to like communicate in full words and
sentences people are so busy like no
they're not what are they do what's
everyone doing not doing anything we've
never been less busy balance of nature
fruits and veggies are a great way to
make sure you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
balance of nature uses an advanced cold
vacuum process to preserve the vitamins
minerals and phytonutrients of the
fruits and vegetables they use the
capsules are whole food supplements with
no additives fillers extracts synthetics
pesticides or added sugar the only thing
in their capsule is pure fruits and
vegetables balance of nature set a bunch
of their products down to the studio for
my team to try we all love them with
balance of nature I get the nutrition of
over 10 servings of fruits and
vegetables and just a few easy to
swallow capsules this makes my crazy
schedule so much more manageable no
matter what my day looks like I start
each morning with my balance of nature
fruits and veggies when you're
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all kinds of benefits
your body will thank you so go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code Walsh
for 35% off your first order as a
preferred customer it's balance ofn
nature.com promo code Walsh for 35% %
off your first preferred order
RZ but I like it you know the other
thing too is that there's this
insistence now that younger Generations
need whole new vocabularies distinct
from older Generations I mean you heard
Oxford English they're they're
celebrating that they're say oh the Gen
Z there they're creating new spaces oh
shut
up first of all not creating anything
they're just taking words that already
exist and they're making them uglier and
um and then but then the effect is that
eventually there's no shared cultural
language anymore each generation has its
own language and I know you'll say it's
always been that way you know younger
kids have always used SL but that's not
really a thing this is actually a modern
phenomenon like if you were to go uh if
you were a farmer in Pennsylvania in the
year 19 or 1827 let's say and you were
45 years
old you you you spoke the same way and
used the same words as your 17-year-old
son there was slang of course but the
slang was shared across
generations and and everything was
shared across Generations they had they
had actually imagine this historically
human beings across the the world have
had a shared culture that spanned
generations and so your grandparents
grandparent and grandchild would
participate in the same culture together
and understand each other and um that's
the way that it used to be and there was
wasn't this thing where every year the
new crop of 17-year-olds invents 50 new
slang terms so that nobody over the age
of of 25 can you know understand
anything they're
saying so I'm opposed to it I'm opposed
to Riz and
situationship and you know kids today
and I'm not saying I'm opposed to slang
but all I'm saying is that kids today
you can use the same slang we used in
the 90s there was nothing wrong with it
like just we can stick with the same
thing for a few decades at least can't
we you don't need new ones our slang was
fine used we used to say stuff like uh
uh talk to the hand and the
bomb and uh eat my shorts is the thing I
mean we didn't really say that but
people on TV said that raise the roof we
used to
say or at least our youth pastors used
to say that to us when they were trying
to relate to us but they were still it
was the slang and it was
fine and we don't need any of this
so it has been
stated if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wallow Twitter page hope to see
you there Godspeed